Lucia:啊哎这也是牛奶
Lucia: Ah, hey, this is also milk
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia:那个好的
Lucia: That one's good
Jake:我靠这已经是汤了
Jake: Gosh, this is already soup
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:这冰淇淋这麦旋风
Jake: This ice cream, this McFlurry
Jake:饮这汤呢有用吗
Jake: Does drinking this soup help?
其他人:有有有
Others: Yes, yes, yes
Jake:那就动一下放到下面就行
Jake: Then just move it down a bit
Alice:你放下边
Alice: You put it down there
Jake:放下面好嘞
Jake: Put it down there, okay
其他人：有只苍蝇掉进去了
Others: A fly fell in
Jake:我操哈哈
Jake: Damn, haha
其他人：不过这个苍蝇朝着就飞过来
Others: But the fly just flew over here
Jake:哈呃自取灭亡
Jake: Haha, self-destruction
Shure: 哈哈没事
Shure: Haha, it's fine
Shure: 高蛋白
Shure: High protein
Jake:给给您吃哈哈
Jake: Here, you eat it, haha
其他人：这个谁的眼镜
Others: Whose glasses are these?
Jake:我靠放放放这我靠
Jake: Gosh, put it down, put it down, gosh
Lucia:哎呦喂sorry
Lucia: Oh my, sorry
Alice:说吃安格斯澳门堡的都是渣女
Alice: They say girls who eat Angus Macau burgers are trashy
Alice:是个捞女
Alice: Gold diggers
Alice:是吗是吗
Alice: Right, right?
Alice:有那个梗是吗对对对
Alice: Is that a meme? Right, right
Alice:你个low女
Alice: You're such a low girl
Shure: 不能吃便宜的
Shure: Can't eat cheap stuff
Shure: 烤这么贵的
Shure: Grill such expensive stuff
Lucia:我点的好像是这个和薯条和热巧克力
Lucia: I think I ordered this with fries and hot chocolate
Jake:盲盒盲盒盲盒
Jake: Blind box, blind box, blind box
Jake:还有谁没挑吗
Jake: Is there anyone who hasn't picked yet?
Lucia:乱拆
Lucia: Randomly pick.
Jake:谁有派吗
Jake: Does anyone have pie?
Jake:派是怎么点的
Jake: How do you order pie?
Alice:是我点我点了两个菜
Alice: I did. I ordered two dishes.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Alice:给你一个
Alice: Here, have one.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:管他呢就当是这个了
Lucia: Whatever, let's just consider it this one.
Jake:薯条薯条都是谁
Jake: Who ordered fries?
Jake:薯条就分着吃吧
Jake: Let's just share the fries.
Jake:但是没有地方放呢要不然
Jake: But there's no place to put them, so...
Jake:怎么找不到呵呵呵呃OK OK
Jake: Why can't I find it? Hahaha, okay, okay.
Lucia:把这一挪
Lucia: Move this.
Jake:哎呀呀呀好损失了8根
Jake: Oh no, we've lost 8 fries.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
Jake:麦当劳薯条
Jake: McDonald's fries.
Katrina: 嗯好冷啊
Katrina: It's so cold.
Jake:薯条这叫什么呀这叫
Jake: What do you call this? This is...
Jake:薯条自由是吗
Jake: Freedom fries, right?
Katrina: 做什么
Katrina: What are you doing?
Tasha: 今天晚上吃这么好我们是要走路了吗
Tasha: We're eating so well tonight, are we going for a walk?
Katrina: 牛排啊
Katrina: Steak, huh?
Tasha: 今天晚上怎么吃这么好是要上路了吗
Tasha: We're eating so well tonight, are we hitting the road?
Katrina: 还有的宝呢
Katrina: What about the treasure?
Jake:呃还还有很多
Jake: Uh, there's still a lot.
Jake:也没有很多了
Jake: Not really a lot.
Jake:还有几个
Jake: Just a few more.
Lucia:为啥你是直接挤在上面的
Lucia: Why did you squeeze it directly on top?
Lucia:我以为是挤在旁边然后站的那种
Lucia: I thought you were going to squeeze it on the side and stand it up.
Jake:哦OK那也行
Jake: Oh, okay, that works too.
Lucia:没事都行
Lucia: It's fine, whatever.
Lucia:无所谓了好
Lucia: Doesn't matter, okay.
Jake:好好挤旁边合理
Jake: Alright, squeezing it on the side makes sense.
其他人:这个能吃了吗
Others: Is this edible now?
Tasha: 这个不可以吃
Tasha: This can't be eaten.
Tasha: 没有摆盘呢
Tasha: It's not plated yet.
Tasha: 杨老师你能把桌子收拾把东西摆一下吗
Tasha: Jake, can you clean the table and set things up?
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Katrina: 还有一盒薯条
Katrina: There's still a box of fries.
Lucia:居然这么多薯条
Lucia: There's so many fries!
Alice:薯条开会
Alice: It's a fries meeting!
Katrina: 哈哈薯条山
Katrina: Haha, it's a mountain of fries!
其他人：哎刚才那包盐去哪
Others: Hey, where did that pack of salt go?
Katrina: 盐我都看到了
Katrina: I saw the salt.
其他人:卧槽
Others: Whoa!
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：在哪了哦看到了看到了
Others: There it is, I see it now.
Alice:太搞笑了
Alice: This is so funny.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 我要小开个会了家人们
Shure: I'm gonna have a little meeting, everyone.
Jake:还有3个宝是谁的
Jake: Whose are these three treasures?
Jake:有一个是我的
Jake: One of them is mine.
Jake:可能吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake:这个可以开
Jake: This one can be opened.
Shure: 要开个会
Shure: Let's have a meeting.
Jake:你关了吧
Jake: You close it.
Jake:你关了吧你开会
Jake: You close it and have the meeting.
Shure: 后面也不记录了
Shure: We won't record after this.
Jake:你再开嘛
Jake: You do it again.
其他人:我靠我草
Others: Whoa!
其他人:感动死我了
Others: I'm so touched.
Jake:我开了啊
Jake: I'm starting it.
Jake:我开了
其他人:呃开会
Others: Uh, meeting.
Lucia:这个拆开放这可以蘸
Lucia: Open this, we can dip.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:虽然我也不知道甜辣酱蘸着好不好吃
Lucia: Though I don't know if sweet chili sauce will taste good.
其他人:他刚让我妈拆开一个bug
Others: He just asked my mom to open a bug.
其他人:他要他来一个我写bug
Others: He wants to write a bug himself.
Lucia:嗯还行
Lucia: Hmm, not bad.
其他人:哎怎么这么多厚牛堡
Others: Why are there so many thick beef burgers?
其他人:卧槽那我点的是哪个
Others: Whoa, which one did I order?
Jake:盲盒盲盒
Jake: Mystery box, mystery box.
Katrina: 凤牛堡还有不一样的吗
Katrina: Are there different thick beef burgers?
其他人:你想想你当时点的那个
Others: Think about which one you ordered.
其他人:我点的我点的应该是培根
Others: I think I ordered the bacon one.
其他人:啊培根
Others: Ah, bacon.
其他人:那可能我给你吃了
Others: Maybe I ate yours.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
其他人:但我记得我点的培根
Others: But I remember I ordered bacon.
其他人：这刚好啊
Others: This is just right.
其他人:怎么还开火了
Others: Why did it catch fire?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
其他人:牛排是不是刘太监的
Others: Is this steak Choiszt's?
其他人：这个蛋挞皮都是你做的
Others: Did you make all these tart crusts?
Katrina: 蛋挞皮是买的
Katrina: The tart crusts are store-bought.
其他人:哦我想起来我菜的菜
Others: Oh, I remember the dish I ordered.
Jake:他怎么发成这样了
Jake: Why did he send it like this?
其他人:不好意思
Others: Sorry.
Jake:我我我
Jake: I-I-I...
Jake:我看看怎么收拾
Jake: Let me see how to clean this up.
Lucia:不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake:这个怎么收掉
Jake: How do we clean this up?
Jake:认领一下放牛排里吧
Jake: Claim it and put it with the steak.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
其他人：之前我在上海实现不是有那个中国总部吗
Others: Before, when I was in Shanghai, wasn’t there a China headquarters?
其他人：天天去吃麦当劳给我吃吐了
Others: I ate McDonald's every day until I got sick of it.
Jake:是这种吗
Jake: Is it like this?
Jake:是一样的
Jake: It's the same.
Jake:这个丢掉哈
Jake: Throw this away.
Jake:丢掉吗丢掉
Jake: Throw it away? Throw it away.
其他人：案板给我一下案板案板
Others: Pass me the cutting board, the cutting board.
Lucia:案板
Lucia: The cutting board.
Tasha: 这是你刚刚切的芒果啊菠萝是吗
Tasha: Is this the mango or pineapple you just cut?
Jake:这有差别吗
Jake: Is there a difference?
其他人：看不出来
Others: I can't tell.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
其他人:今天中午吃汉堡晚上吃麦当劳
Others: Burger for lunch, McDonald's for dinner.
Katrina: 我要坐一下走累了
Katrina: I need to sit for a bit, I'm tired from walking.
Alice:还有垃圾吗
Alice: Is there any trash?
Jake:有垃圾袋
Jake: There's a trash bag.
Jake:这边有垃圾袋
Jake: There's a trash bag here.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Lucia:这我的还没吃完
Lucia: I haven't finished mine yet.
Lucia:现在我想着先在这放一下
Lucia: For now, I'll just leave it here.
Lucia:然后整理一下
Lucia: Then I'll tidy up.
其他人：这是什么
Others: What is this?
Katrina: 蛋清
Katrina: Egg whites.
Alice:蛋清
Alice: Egg white
其他人：这是你的吗
Others: Is this yours?
Katrina: 不是公共的
Katrina: No, it's communal.
Jake:大伙了大伙了
Jake: Everyone, everyone.
Alice:蛋黄打打进那里面了
Alice: The egg yolk got mixed in there.
Jake:蘸个酱
Jake: Dip it in some sauce.
Jake:哦这还有个
Jake: Oh, there's another one.
Jake:我靠开不了啊
Jake: Damn, I can't open it.
Alice:你在欣赏自己的作品吗
Alice: Are you admiring your own work?
Alice:无纺一分熟也是熟
Alice: Half-cooked non-woven is still cooked.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Jake:我把酱开了
Jake: I opened the sauce.
Jake:鸡块没了
Jake: The nuggets are gone.
Jake:哈哈是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
Jake:还有两只
Jake: There are two left.
Jake:在哪啊瞎不好意思
Jake: Where are they? Oh, sorry.
其他人：我发现我吃
Others: I found I eat...
Lucia:不是这个也可以蘸
Lucia: This can be dipped too.
其他人:吃麦当劳为什么不需要蘸酱
Others: Why don't you need sauce with McDonald's?
其他人：这我能吃
Others: I can eat this.
Jake:为什么呢不知道
Jake: Why? I don't know.
其他人：不知道
Others: I don't know.
其他人： 我之前买麦当劳少吃绿茶
Others: I used to eat less green tea at McDonald's.
其他人：我会专门
Others: I would...
其他人：退市里面不用给我放酱
Others: Especially request no sauce.
Katrina: 您是哪人啊
Katrina: Where are you from?
Alice:无妨
Alice: No problem.
Katrina: 我听不出一点口音
Katrina: I can't hear any accent.
其他人：河南
Others: Henan.
Katrina: 所以我很好奇
Katrina: So I'm curious.
Katrina: 嗯我当时还以为你是北京人
Katrina: Hmm, I thought you were from Beijing.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
其他人:我说话没有京爷味
Others: I don't speak with a Beijing accent.
其他人:味道不纯
Others: It's not authentic.
Katrina: 感觉有一点哈
Katrina: It feels a little bit like it though.
其他人:但
Others: But
其他人:我确实很好的融入了北京的社会环境
Others: I have really integrated well into Beijing's social environment.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:怎么热爱挤地
Jake: How to love squeezing land
Jake:铁哼哼哼
Jake: Iron hum hum hum
其他人:不热爱挤地铁天天打车上下班
Others: I don't like squeezing into the subway; I take a cab to work every day.
其他人:真的
Others: Really.
其他人:我在北京上海实习之后我喜欢上海
Others: After interning in both Beijing and Shanghai, I prefer Shanghai.
其他人:最重要一点就是
Others: The most important thing is
其他人:因为我在上海打车便宜
Others: because taking a cab in Shanghai is cheaper.
其他人:因为上海最省
Others: Because Shanghai saves money.
Lucia:哇哦
Lucia: Wow.
Alice:哈哈哈哎
Alice: Hahaha, hey.
其他人：哎你这个时候应该给你哎
Others: Hey, at this moment, you should...
其他人：给他找点盐
Others: Give him some salt.
其他人：对我还没到
Others: Right, I'm not there yet.
其他人：不不你当就
Others: No, no, you just...
其他人：就这样就这样哈哈哈
Others: Just like that, just like that. Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人：撒盐哥那个撒法
Others: Like Salt Bae, the way he sprinkles salt.
其他人：一定要把那个手腕能有多畸形多畸形
Others: You have to make your wrist as contorted as possible.
其他人：然后给你拍一个
Others: Then we'll take a picture of you.
其他人：撒盐哥那个撒法
Others: Like Salt Bae, the way he sprinkles salt.
其他人：啊我盐放到哪了
Others: Ah, where did I put the salt?
Alice:那不是哎
Alice: Isn't it over there?
Alice:那不是吗
Alice: Isn't that right?
Alice:那不是盐吗
Alice: Isn't that salt?
Alice:那个那个
Alice: That, that one.
Jake:开摆
Jake: Let's get started.
Jake:开摆开摆
Jake: Let's get started, let's get started.
Katrina: 这洗了吗
Katrina: Has this been washed?
Tasha: 用那个湿纸巾擦一擦
Tasha: Just wipe it with a wet tissue.
Lucia:厨房纸
Lucia: Kitchen paper.
Alice:哈哈等一下拍你你要摆一下吗
Alice: Haha, wait a second, when you pose for the photo, will you strike a pose?
Tasha: 厨房用纸擦一下没有洗洁精
Tasha: Wipe it with kitchen paper, there's no dish soap.
Lucia:就可以用这个吗
Lucia: Can we use this one?
Lucia:不能只能用那那个那种纸吗
Lucia: Or can we only use that kind of paper?
Lucia:湿纸巾湿纸巾
Lucia: Wet tissue, wet tissue.
Jake:撒盐啊或者餐巾纸加水也行
Jake: Sprinkle some salt, or you can use a napkin with water.
Tasha: 或者餐巾纸加水也行
Tasha: Or a napkin with water will do too.
Jake:撒一个撒一个
Jake: Sprinkle it, sprinkle it.
Lucia:要不拿那个
Lucia: How about we use that?
Jake:撒了吧你
Jake: Just sprinkle it already.
Tasha: 餐巾纸加水
Tasha: Napkin with water.
Jake:还没撒呢
Jake: Haven't sprinkled it yet.
Lucia:拿这个加水好了
Lucia: Just add water with this.
Tasha: 厨房纸巾加水也行
Tasha: Kitchen paper towels with water work too.
Alice:撒过了
Alice: Already sprinkled.
Jake:打他是不是从那边外面拍
Jake: Should we film him from outside?
Jake:从外面拍从外面拍
Jake: Film from outside, from outside.
其他人:这个这个直接装盘吗
Others: Should we just plate this directly?
Lucia:哇看起来好好吃
Lucia: Wow, it looks so delicious.
Lucia:好好看啊
Lucia: It looks so good.
Tasha: 就差这两个托盘
Tasha: Just missing these two trays.
Tasha: 我想想现在用到应该就是
Tasha: Let me think, we should use them now.
Lucia:如果我们害怕他太腥了的话也
Lucia: If we're worried it's too fishy...
Lucia:是不是可以给底下铺一层那个
Lucia: Should we put a layer of that...
Lucia:那个那个叫什么
Lucia: What's it called...
Lucia:油纸还是烘焙纸那种纸
Lucia: Parchment paper or baking paper.
Lucia:因为感觉这个刚拆开的话
Lucia: Because it feels like when you first open it...
Lucia:不知道他有一些味什么的
Lucia: You don't know if it has some sort of smell or something.
Lucia:散散散完了没有
Lucia: Is it gone, is it gone yet?
Lucia:对要不就铺一个那个对在最底下有
Lucia: Yeah, maybe put a layer at the bottom.
Alice:铺一下那个油纸吧
Alice: Lay down the parchment paper.
Katrina: 有油纸吗
Katrina: Do we have any parchment paper?
Alice:我拿一下在这里吧我记得
Alice: Let me get it, it's here, I remember.
Katrina: 这是在为明天做准备吗
Katrina: Is this for tomorrow?
Lucia:应该是吧
Lucia: Probably.
Alice:怎么这么烂
Alice: Why is it so bad?
Tasha: 应该是不铺比较好看一些
Tasha: It might look better without laying it.
Lucia:对他这个是有一点颜色还会
Lucia: Yeah, it has some color, and...
Lucia:如果一用水一擦还会掉一些
Lucia: If you wipe it with water, some might come off.
Alice:铺吗
Alice: Lay it?
Alice:那我搁那了
Alice: I'll just put it there.
其他人：这个放在那
Others: Put it there.
Jake:哼干热泡面然后开始上菜
Jake: Hmph, dry instant noodles and then start serving.
其他人:真的刘帅
Others: Really, Choiszt.
其他人:我要是女生我嫁
Others: If I were a girl, I'd marry you.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵可惜
Jake: Hahaha, too bad.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia:啊sorry可惜
Lucia: Ah, sorry, too bad.
Alice:可以直接捏吗
Alice: Can I just squeeze it?
其他人：可惜
Others: Too bad.
Jake:可惜啊
Jake: Too bad.
其他人：可惜啊男生也没事哦
Others: Too bad, it's okay for guys too.
Lucia:吃一个哦
Lucia: Eat one.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mhm.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:嗯好吃
Jake: Mhm, delicious.
Jake:确实可以确实可以
Jake: It’s really good, really good.
Lucia:哇
Lucia: Wow.
Jake:确实很可以
Jake: It's really good.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
其他人:凑巧做做成了一次
Others: Just happened to make it right this time.
其他人:有没有非常的谦虚啊
Others: Isn’t he very modest?
其他人:如果我是一个女生
Others: If I were a girl,
其他人:我就非常喜欢谦虚的男人
Others: I'd really like a humble guy.
其他人:哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 你的掩盖不了你爱上他的事实
Katrina: You can't hide the fact that you love him.
其他人:我自从有一次点了麦当劳的牛奶
Others: Ever since I ordered McDonald's milk once,
其他人:麦当劳的牛奶非常的牛
Others: McDonald's milk is really strong.
Jake:嗯好喝
Jake: Mhm, tasty.
Lucia:这渣怎么掉不出来啊
Lucia: Why won’t this residue come out?
Jake:渣木头渣
Jake: It's wood residue.
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia:就是拿拿厨房纸擦一下的话
Lucia: If you wipe it with kitchen paper,
Lucia:厨房纸会掉一些小渣
Lucia: The paper leaves some bits behind.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:这里面也铺那个啥算了
Lucia: We should line it with parchment paper inside.
Lucia:也铺那个油纸算
Lucia: Line it with parchment paper.
其他人:我看啥时候跟女朋友分手
Others: I’ll see when I break up with my girlfriend.
Lucia:放我这
Lucia: Keep it with me.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你要嫁了哈哈
Katrina: You're going to get married, haha.
Lucia:再来一个
Lucia: Have another one.
其他人:哈哈哈时间管理大师
Others: Hahaha, time management master.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:给薇薇留一个
Alice: Save one for Vivi.
其他人:你女朋友也北邮的
Others: Is your girlfriend also from BUPT?
其他人:不是
Others: No.
其他人:你女朋友也北邮的
Others: Is your girlfriend also from BUPT?
Alice:给薇薇
Alice: Save one for Vivi.
其他人:不是
Others: No.
其他人:他在北京吗
Others: Is he in Beijing?
其他人:对
Others: Yes.
Jake:今天还要做几道几道甜点
Jake: Today we still need to make a few more desserts.
Jake:快完成的3道
Jake: Almost done with three.
其他人：他眼镜没电了
Others: His glasses ran out of battery.
Jake:会优秀员工
Jake: We'll get the outstanding employee.
Jake:这就是一路在记录
Jake: We've been recording everything along the way.
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where did everyone go?
Jake:开会啊
Jake: Have a meeting.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh my!
Lucia:但是还挺好吃
Lucia: But it's still quite delicious.
Jake:你们明天都呃决定了
Jake: Have you all decided for tomorrow?
Jake:几个人啊
Jake: How many people?
Katrina: 一个嗯
Katrina: One, um.
Jake:一个
Jake: One.
Jake:几个
Jake: How many?
Jake:哼哼哼你有一堆啊
Jake: Haha, you have a bunch!
其他人:嗯对
Others: Yeah, right.
其他人:这环球拉人魂未取消啊
Others: This global pull hasn't been canceled.
Jake:走现在走
Jake: Let's go, let's go now.
Jake:呵呵呵没有没有没有取消了
Jake: Haha, no, no, it's been canceled.
Jake:怕怕外边的人挺麻烦
Jake: Afraid that people outside might be troublesome.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:卖门票对
Jake: Selling tickets, right.
Jake:看看能不能把这几天本给回了
Jake: Let's see if we can recover the cost for these days.
其他人:我跟你讲
Others: Let me tell you.
其他人:你去海淀黄庄门口
Others: Go to the gate of Haidian Huangzhuang.
Jake:海淀黄庄
Jake: Haidian Huangzhuang?
其他人：与你孩子一家人 30年后
Others: With your family, 30 years later.
Jake:我靠我靠
Jake: Oh my god, oh my god.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：哎你说他们都1,000多人
Others: You said they all have over a thousand people.
Jake:不是你组个名字就一天
Jake: No, you form a group just for one day.
Jake:开玩笑呵呵可以
Jake: Just kidding, haha, it's possible.
其他人：什么
Others: What?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Jake:才才数一天吗
Jake: Just for one day?
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Alice:你来你的孩子
Alice: You and your kids.
其他人:你的孩子
Others: Your kids.
其他人:将来有可能会出现在我们的论文里面
Others: This might appear in our future papers.
其他人:我们是做AI的
Others: We work in AI.
其他人:你知道我们女子今年开始的高峰赛道
Others: You know about our women's peak season track starting this year.
其他人::你不想想你的孩子不能输在起跑
Others: Don't you want to make sure your kid doesn't fall behind from the start?
其他人:孩子升到初中正好结婚
Others: When the kid enters junior high, it's perfect for marriage.
其他人:是开初中赛道了
Others: They're starting the junior high track.
其他人:对
Others: Yeah.
Lucia:哎呦对不起对不起
Lucia: Oh, sorry, sorry.
其他人:海淀皇上那味可抽
Others: The taste of Haidian Emperor can be addictive.
其他人:我操我知道海淀皇上初中
Others: Damn, I know about Haidian Emperor's junior high.
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Alice:妈呀还薯条泛滥了
Alice: Oh my gosh, the fries are everywhere.
其他人:那你不是在海淀皇上捡生捡死吗
Others: Aren't you struggling with the Haidian Emperor's courses?
Lucia:好多呀
Lucia: There's so many.
其他人:我感觉
Others: I feel...
其他人:我感觉你应该不属于那种极度激娃的
Others: I feel like you're not the type to push your kid extremely hard.
其他人:真的吗
Others: Really?
其他人:还有我身边的人都是小学
Others: Also, the people around me are all about elementary school.
Katrina: 这好可爱
Katrina: This is so cute.
其他人:初中什么上课的班的人
Others: What about junior high classes?
Katrina: 比那个比那个网图要好看哎
Katrina: It's even better looking than the online pictures.
其他人:都是都带海带王装啊
Others: They all wear seaweed king outfits?
其他人:都带海带王装吗
Others: Do they all wear seaweed king outfits?
其他人:对这都是什么人大富人我
Others: Yeah, they're all wealthy people.
Katrina: 还有一个大的尾巴
Katrina: And there's a big tail too.
其他人:感觉我跟他们人大富人接触一下
Others: I feel like I should interact with those wealthy people.
其他人:他们人大富人确实挺厉害的
Others: Those wealthy people are really impressive.
Katrina: 很可爱
Katrina: So cute.
Katrina: 爽了
Katrina: Satisfied.
其他人:哎你
Others: Hey, you...
其他人:你身上有有人大富人吗
Others: Do you have any wealthy people around you?
Katrina: 不这是我自己的
Katrina: No, this is my own.
其他人:有叫啥
Katrina: 他送我还差不多
Katrina: He gave it to me, close enough.
Alice:我可以看一下吗
Alice: Can I take a look?
Katrina: 我送
Katrina: I gave...
Katrina: 嗯抱着没事
Katrina: Yeah, hold it, no problem.
Katrina: 这是我公费埋汰
Katrina: This is my public expense, trash talk.
Alice:这是狐狸吗
Alice: Is this a fox?
Katrina: 对公费吗
Katrina: Yeah, public expense, right?
其他人：跟他说这个
Others: Tell him this.
其他人：这个菜也太可爱了吧
Others: This dish is just too cute.
其他人：我一定要嫁给这一生
Others: I definitely want to marry the person who made this.
其他人：第一个送给我这个菜的人
Others: The first person who gives me this dish.
Alice:谢谢好可爱
Alice: Thank you, it's so cute.
Katrina: 哈哈哎
Katrina: Haha, hey.
其他人:是不
Others: Right?
其他人：这个人到底在哪啊
Others: Where is this person anyway?
Katrina: 直接把我删了到最后
Katrina: They just deleted me in the end.
其他人:对
Others: Yeah.
其他人:非常的非常的夸张
Others: It's really, really exaggerated.
Katrina: 耶
Katrina: Yay!
其他人:这
Others: This...
其他人:我之前是参加此期实践的时候认识的
Others: I met them when I participated in this practice session.
其他人:当时我也能打
Others: At that time, I could also fight.
其他人:所以名县人越多越好
Others: So, the more people from Ming County, the better.
Jake:你开两辆车过来
Jake: Bring two cars over.
其他人:又堵车没有没有没有
Others: It's jammed again. No, no, no.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:这可以别人也开吗
Jake: Can others drive this too?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:这个应该快没那个存储了
Alice: This is probably almost out of storage.
Alice:停吗
Alice: Should we stop?
Jake:看一下呃
Jake: Let's check, um...
Alice:呃我看我的
Alice: Uh, let me check mine.
Jake:就等没清楚就停吧
Jake: Just stop when it's not clear.
Jake:就是咱也还有
Jake: We still have...
Jake:还有还有半个小时
Jake: We still have half an hour.
Jake:没有就是这一轮33
Jake: No, just this round, 33.
Alice:3333
Alice: 3333.
Jake:对啊半个小时
Jake: Yeah, half an hour.
Jake:一个小时40分钟吧
Jake: An hour and 40 minutes, right?
Alice:甜品师傅
Alice: Pastry chef.
Katrina: 哎呀手机呢
Katrina: Oh no, where's my phone?
Katrina: （歌词）失去一种清醒
Katrina: (Lyrics) Losing a kind of clarity.
Katrina: （歌词）明白你背着我聪明
Katrina: (Lyrics) Understanding that you're smart behind my back.
Katrina: （歌词）真的懂回忆的秘密
Katrina: (Lyrics) Truly understanding the secret of memories.
Lucia:哈哈哈那个没法炫我嘴里
Lucia: Hahaha, that can't show off in my mouth.
Lucia:会炫我脸上
Lucia: It will show off on my face.
Jake:那我现在鼠标上吧
Jake: Alright, I'll use the mouse now.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:抹茶粉太贵了
Lucia: Matcha powder is too expensive.
Katrina: （歌词）我多希望你能理清
Katrina: (Lyrics) I wish you could understand
Katrina: （歌词）如蜜侥幸那么动人
Katrina: (Lyrics) Sweet serendipity so charming
其他人：哎那个狐狸能让我看看吗
Others: Hey, can I see that fox?
Katrina: 哦我放上去了
Katrina: Oh, I put it up.
Katrina: 我给你拿下来
Katrina: I'll take it down for you.
其他人：好看我也买
Others: Looks good, I'll buy one too.
Katrina: 很好看那个系列的性价比都比较高
Katrina: It's really nice, that series has a good value for money.
Katrina: 还有还有一个就是
Katrina: And there's another one...
Katrina: 如果你想放床上的话
Katrina: If you want to put it on your bed,
Katrina: 我比较推荐一个狮子
Katrina: I recommend a lion.
Katrina: 还有那个就是一个企鹅
Katrina: And there's also a penguin.
Katrina: 不是那个花生企鹅是这
Katrina: Not the peanut penguin, but the big one.
Katrina: 个大的那个
Katrina: That big one.
Katrina: 企鹅那几个抱着特别舒服
Katrina: The penguin is super comfy to hug.
其他人：企鹅
Others: Penguin?
Katrina: 那企鹅超舒服
Katrina: That penguin is super comfy.
其他人：先买狮子和狐企鹅可以去腾讯的文创店买
Others: First get the lion and fox, you can buy the penguin at Tencent's cultural store.
Katrina: 给你拿下来
Katrina: I'll take it down for you.
Katrina: 那曲终清晰
Katrina: Then the melody becomes clear.
其他人:这是
Others: This is...
其他人:这是有排版的呀
Others: This has formatting!
其他人:我靠
Others: Wow.
其他人:非常的高级
Others: Very high-end.
其他人:为什么一个6一个5个上面要放草莓
Others: Why is there a strawberry on one 6 and one 5?
其他人:为什么一个6一个5个
Others: Why one 6 and one 5?
其他人：哇看确实不错哎
Others: Wow, it does look nice.
其他人：这个200多块钱嗯
Others: This is over 200 bucks, huh?
Lucia:你想吃哪个吃哪个
Lucia: Eat whichever one you want.
其他人：哇这个真不错哎
Others: Wow, this is really nice.
Katrina: 这个系列的
Katrina: This series...
Katrina: 手感很好
Katrina: Feels really nice.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
其他人：这是啥IP吗
Others: What IP is this?
Katrina: 嗯什么IP
Katrina: Hmm, what IP?
Katrina: 不是
Katrina: No.
Katrina: 什么叫IP啊
Katrina: What's IP?
其他人：就是比如什么联名之类的
Others: Like a collaboration or something.
Katrina: 没有没有
Katrina: No, no.
Katrina: 就是普通的
Katrina: Just normal ones.
其他人：就是链接发我
Others: Just send me the link.
其他人：链接发给你可以
Others: Yeah, send you the link, sure.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 我之前我第一个是在杭州线下买的
Katrina: The first one I bought was offline in Hangzhou.
Jake:哎呀这个挪一挪
Jake: Oh, let's move this a bit.
Katrina: 对线下门店只有几个城市有
Katrina: Yeah, only a few cities have offline stores.
Katrina: 嗯北京国贸也有
Katrina: Yeah, there's one in Beijing World Trade Center too.
Katrina: 我想想啊对他我一共有几个
Katrina: Let me think... Yeah, I have a few of them.
其他人：这个小狐狸就一直带在你身边了
Others: This little fox is always with you.
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 不脱手了
Katrina: Never letting go.
Katrina: 我买了这个
Katrina: I bought this one.
Katrina: 你看他们都属于一个系列的
Katrina: Look, they all belong to the same series.
Katrina: 叫什么波
Katrina: What's it called...
Jake:哦好吸
Jake: Oh, so absorbing.
Katrina: 我之前买了这个
Katrina: I bought this one before.
其他人：哦看起来都不错哎
Others: Oh, they all look nice.
其他人：这两个都很好
Others: Both are great.
其他人：这个傻逼几个
Others: How many of these idiots...
Alice:给它融了
Alice: Melt it down.
其他人：是我女朋友前男友送我的
Others: My girlfriend's ex-boyfriend gave it to me.
Jake:哦好好好好好交错
Jake: Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay, cross paths.
Katrina: 好哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha, okay.
Katrina: 这很这很舒服
Katrina: This is very comfortable.
Katrina: 这跟这一个系列的
Katrina: It's from the same series.
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: And...
Tasha: 快吃快吃
Tasha: Eat quickly, eat quickly.
Tasha: 别拍了
Tasha: Stop filming.
Tasha: 大家快吃
Tasha: Everyone, eat up.
Katrina: 应该都是这种
Katrina: They should all be like this.
Katrina: 然后还有一个
Katrina: And there's another one.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Katrina: 那个企鹅我跟你说长那个样子
Katrina: That penguin, I told you, looks like that.
Katrina: 那个手感很好
Katrina: It feels great.
Jake:我每天都在这种surprising中
Jake: I'm surprised every day.
Jake:来吃吃吃
Jake: Come on, eat, eat, eat.
Katrina: 好多种企鹅哦
Katrina: So many kinds of penguins!
其他人：还可以给他加围巾
Others: You can also give him a scarf.
Katrina: 不是这种企鹅
Katrina: Not that kind of penguin.
Katrina: 叫什么企鹅
Katrina: What kind of penguin?
Jake:大师您先吃您先吃
Jake: Master, please eat first, go ahead.
其他人：就长这样
Others: It looks like this.
Jake:您先吃下一个
Jake: You eat the next one.
其他人：这没那么舒服
Others: This is not that comfortable.
Jake:哈哈哎
Jake: Haha, hey.
其他人：叫什么脖
Others: What's it called?
Lucia:擦了但是他那个渣就会粘在上面
Lucia: Wiped it, but the crumbs still stick to it.
Katrina: 嗯忘了讨厌企鹅
Katrina: Mm, forgot, hate penguins.
其他人：讨厌企鹅
Others: Hate penguins.
Lucia:就是厨房纸会被他那个木头
Lucia: The kitchen paper gets stuck on the wood.
其他人：哈哈哈卧槽
Others: Hahaha, damn.
Lucia:挂掉
Lucia: Hung up.
Lucia:所以我那那里面也垫一个
Lucia: So, I'll put one in there too.
其他人：还在送企鹅哎
Others: Still sending penguins, huh?
Lucia:等一下我刚哎刚那个
Lucia: Wait a moment, I just, hey, just...
Katrina: 送我前男友送的企鹅
Katrina: The penguin my ex-boyfriend sent me.
其他人：你不会还留着吧
Others: You didn't keep it, right?
Katrina: 啊啊哈哈
Katrina: Ah ah, haha.
Katrina: 哭了
Katrina: Cried.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: 哈哈这个这个系这个很舒服哦
Katrina: Haha, this, this one is really comfortable, oh.
Katrina: 这个很舒服
Katrina: This one is really comfortable.
其他人:傻逼企鹅狗都别买
Others: Stupid penguin, don't even buy dogs.
Jake:什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
其他人:没事我买这个
Others: Never mind, I bought this.
其他人:就是我女朋友的前男友
Others: It's my girlfriend's ex-boyfriend.
其他人:送我女朋友的是企鹅
Others: Sent my girlfriend a penguin.
其他人:他送给他前男友的是企鹅啊
Others: He sent his ex-boyfriend a penguin.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人:他送给他前男友的是企鹅哦
Others: He sent his ex-boyfriend a penguin too.
其他人:我女朋友的前男友送我女朋友的
Others: My girlfriend's ex-boyfriend sent her...
其他人:也是企鹅
Others: A penguin too.
Katrina: 就是他被绿的那个啊
Katrina: It's the one who got cheated on.
其他人:不是不是不是我现在的女朋友
Others: No, no, not my current girlfriend.
Katrina: 你现在女朋友的前男友哦
Katrina: Your current girlfriend's ex-boyfriend, oh.
其他人:你天呐
Others: Oh my god.
Jake:建立了连接
Jake: Connection established.
其他人：反正就是
Others: Anyway, it's just
Jake:collected
Jake: collected
其他人：反正就是企鹅不好
Others: Anyway, penguins are bad
Katrina: 嗯企鹅坏
Katrina: Yeah, penguins are bad
Katrina: 企鹅坏人
Katrina: Penguins are bad guys
Katrina: 好好
Katrina: Okay, okay
其他人:好我立马辞职
Others: Alright, I'll resign immediately
其他人:为了你我加入自己哈哈哈
Others: For you, I'll join myself, hahaha
Katrina: 哎呀哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Oh no, hahaha
Katrina: 我找的海淘
Katrina: I found it through overseas shopping
Katrina: 因为他这种一般就会现货
Katrina: Because generally, this kind of stuff is in stock
Katrina: 没货了
Katrina: It's out of stock now
Katrina: 再给你找一
Katrina: I'll find another one for you
其他人：哦原来这个Jelly开的叫吉利帽
Others: Oh, so this Jelly's hat is called a Ghillie hat
Katrina: 这种这种就是库存只有几个的
Katrina: This kind, this kind only has a few in stock
Katrina: 一般是个人海淘
Katrina: Usually it's personally shopped overseas
Jake:我先把这个收了吧
Jake: I'll just take this first
Katrina: 就是他们从官网下单
Katrina: They order directly from the official website
Katrina: 然后要等一个月什么的
Katrina: And have to wait for like a month or so
Katrina: 然后这种的话就比较真
Katrina: And this kind is more genuine
Jake:我靠这很难很难补汤
Jake: Damn, it's really hard to find a replacement
Katrina: 要么就官网买
Katrina: Or just buy from the official website
Katrina: 官网经常没货
Katrina: The official site often runs out of stock
Katrina: 找找
Katrina: Let me look
Katrina: 我觉得就这个系列性价比比较高
Katrina: I think this series has good value for money
Katrina: 像这种小11
Katrina: Like this little 11
Katrina: 你看这种
Katrina: Look at this
Katrina: 这种系列就很性价比不高
Katrina: This series doesn't have good value for money
Katrina: 你看160一个
Katrina: Look, 160 for one
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina: 这个就这么大
Katrina: And it's this small
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
其他人：还小这种
Others: It's still small
其他人：然后就送人的
Others: And then just give it as a gift
其他人：送人啊
Others: Give it as a gift
其他人：那就别送企鹅
Others: Then don't give it to penguins
Jake:Katrina:
Jake: Katrina:
其他人：不是说买这个吗
Others: Didn't we say to buy this?
其他人：对对对就买这个是正确的
Others: Yeah, yeah, buying this is the right choice
Jake:我看看
Jake: Let me see
其他人：非常的好
Others: Very good.
其他人：非常的好看啊
Others: Really nice!
其他人：这个非常好看
Others: This looks great.
Jake:这是狐狸对
Jake: This is a fox, right?
Katrina: 对我给你找找啊我感觉
Katrina: Yeah, let me find it for you, I think...
Katrina: 我要看一下
Katrina: I need to check.
Katrina: 你看这都是一个系列哦
Katrina: Look, these are all in the same series.
其他人：看起来好像有狐狸
Others: Looks like there's a fox.
其他人：但是没货
Others: But it's out of stock.
其他人：有点像波浪猫狐狸
Others: Kind of like a wavy cat-fox.
Katrina: 居然吗断货吗这狐狸
Katrina: Really? Is this fox out of stock?
Katrina: 这狐狸有点丑
Katrina: This fox is kind of ugly.
其他人： 确实没没这个好看
Others: Yeah, not as nice as this one.
其他人：嗯你的那个店家已经缺货了吗
Others: Hmm, is your shop out of stock?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 才几天啊这
Katrina: How many days has it been?
Katrina: 没货了真的
Katrina: It's really out of stock.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 波浪毛狐狸
Katrina: Wavy haired fox.
Tasha: 用一个容器
Tasha: Use a container.
Katrina: 都没货了
Katrina: It's all out of stock.
Jake:容器
Jake: Container.
Jake:真圆
Jake: So round.
其他人：靠
Others: Damn.
其他人：京东上倒是有
Others: There's some on JD.
其他人：369 有点过分了
Others: 369, that's a bit much.
Katrina: 他怎么溢价呢
Katrina: Why is it overpriced?
其他人： 还有217咖啡液
Others: There's also 217 coffee liquid.
Alice:可以可以
Alice: Okay, okay.
其他人：嗯就这个是吧
Others: Yeah, this is it, right?
其他人：对这个好
Others: Yeah, this one's good.
Katrina: 你确定你看一下这个是
Katrina: Are you sure? Look at this.
Katrina: 这我不太知道
Katrina: I don't really know.
Katrina: 京东这个是个人买件还是什么
Katrina: Is this JD one a personal purchase or what?
Katrina: 害怕你被坑的
Katrina: Afraid you'll get scammed.
Alice:咖啡液
Alice: Coffee liquid.
Lucia: 是那天那个刀吗
Lucia: Is it that knife from that day?
其他人：那这个怎么判断呢
Others: How do you judge this?
其他人：个人买家真的可能性就高是吗
Others: Personal buyers are more likely, right?
Lucia:那天那天杨老板切蛋糕那个刀吗
Lucia: That day, the knife Jake used to cut the cake?
Katrina: 他自己买
Katrina: He bought it himself.
Katrina: 就是就是京东
Katrina: Like, from JD.com.
Katrina: 的话他也有个人买家入驻吗
Katrina: Do they also have individual buyers on JD.com?
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Alice:一样的
Alice: It's the same.
其他人：啊我的评价是直接闲鱼
Others: Ah, my review is directly on Xianyu.
Jake:看到咖啡叶
Jake: Saw the coffee leaves.
Katrina: 闲鱼很多假的耶
Katrina: There are a lot of fakes on Xianyu.
Jake:这个吗
Jake: This one?
Katrina: 看一下这家店他的库存啊什么的
Katrina: Check out the store's inventory and stuff.
Lucia:咖啡液
Lucia: Coffee liquid.
Lucia:是咱们那天那个绿色的那个吗
Lucia: Is it the green one we had that day?
其他人：哎这个不是吗
Others: Hey, isn't this the one?
其他人：刚刚上面的
Others: The one from just now.
Lucia:就是这也行啊
Lucia: This one works too.
Jake:瑞幸咖啡业
Jake: Luckin Coffee leaves.
Lucia:瑞幸咖啡叶拆一下
Lucia: Unpack the Luckin Coffee leaves.
Katrina: 这不对这家不对
Katrina: This isn't right, this store isn't right.
Jake:都不知道为什么出现在这
Jake: I don't even know why it showed up here.
Katrina: 这个东西一家都两百多
Katrina: This item costs over 200.
Katrina: 他不可能卖149的
Katrina: It can't be sold for 149.
Jake:不知道怎么是怎么就买了呢
Jake: Don't know how he bought it.
Lucia:他突然就出现在了需要用的地方
Lucia: It suddenly appeared where it was needed.
其他人：好有经验啊这个
Others: So experienced.
Lucia:很好
Lucia: Very good.
Katrina: 这一款一家不止1400一49
Katrina: This model costs more than 1400, not 149.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh my.
Alice:怪会摆的
Alice: So good at displaying.
其他人：好有经验对
Others: Very experienced, right.
Jake:怎么怎么怎么买
Jake: How, how do you buy it?
其他人：非常有经验
Others: Very experienced.
Katrina: 这不可能只有149
Katrina: It can't be only 149.
Jake:这个200多块钱
Jake: This is over 200 yuan.
Katrina: 这个200多块钱
Katrina: This is over 200 yuan.
Jake:判断什么
Jake: How to judge?
Katrina: 而且会而且会有溢价
Katrina: And it might have a premium.
其他人:他就看库存就能看出来
Others: He can tell by looking at the inventory.
其他人:这个东西他觉得真不真哦
Others: He can tell if it's real or not.
其他人:哎这还都响
Others: Oh, this one makes sound.
Jake:对新乐器
Jake: Yes, it's a new instrument.
Katrina: 对啊哈
Katrina: Yeah, haha
Lucia:哇好开了
Lucia: Wow, it's so open now
Alice: 25毫升还要多少
Alice: How much more for the 25 milliliters?
Katrina: 但是一家也没必要
Katrina: But it's not necessary for just one family
Katrina: 你你着急送人吗
Katrina: Are you in a hurry to give it to someone?
其他人：那也不太急吧
Others: Not really in a hurry
Katrina: 送女生啊确实
Katrina: Giving it to a girl, indeed
其他人:确实哦这个咖啡业买还派上用场
Others: Indeed, this coffee is still useful
Jake:呵呵板砖的是吧
Jake: Haha, is it a brick one?
Katrina: 可以问一下
Katrina: Can I ask something?
Jake:哈哈哈本来是想来缩的是吧哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, you originally wanted to shrink it, right? Hahaha
Katrina: 那我帮你找找吧
Katrina: Let me help you find it
Katrina: 今天晚上再帮你找
Katrina: I'll help you find it tonight
Katrina: 我的小狮
Katrina: My little lion
Katrina: 我的小狐狸
Katrina: My little fox
Alice:等一下等一下
Alice: Wait a minute, wait a minute
Katrina: 我靠居然买那家
Katrina: Wow, you actually bought from that store
Alice:我靠居然买了一家奶酪
Alice: Wow, you actually bought cheese from that store
Katrina: 马上就断货了
Katrina: It's going to be out of stock soon
Lucia:没事
Lucia: It's okay
Lucia:其实那个奶酪也是我家带的死货
Lucia: Actually, that cheese was dead stock from my home
Lucia:不过反正也吃上了哈哈
Lucia: But anyway, we ate it, haha
Katrina: （歌词）小蝴蝶我是你的小阿飞
Katrina: (Lyrics) Little butterfly, I am your little Afei
Katrina: 我靠还没拍照
Katrina: Wow, I haven't even taken a picture
其他人:我靠这摆盘有点怎么怎么
Others: Wow, this plating is a bit...
其他人:又低了一下头就已经摆完了
Others: Looked down for a moment and it's already plated
其他人:我操你吃完了
Others: Damn, you finished it
其他人：等一下等一下等一下
Others: Wait, wait, wait
Jake:又低了一下头
Jake: Looked down again
其他人：没摆好
Others: It's not plated well
其他人:放上去放上去
Others: Put it on, put it on
其他人: 放上去
Others: Put it on
Katrina: 这是今天晚上吃的还是明天的
Katrina: Is this for tonight or tomorrow?
Lucia:摆热水呃那现在现场烧一个
Lucia: Put it in hot water, um, let's boil one now
Jake:这一会再撒撒肉松
Jake: We'll sprinkle some meat floss later
Alice:热水壶在那呢
Alice: The kettle is over there
Lucia:热水壶是不俩都在楼上啊
Lucia: Aren't both kettles upstairs?
Lucia:我去拿吧
Lucia: I'll go get it
Alice:他他脚那
Alice: By his foot
其他人：摆不上了
Others: It can't be placed
Alice:这个这个这桌子底下
Alice: Under the table, this one.
Lucia:啊楼下有吗
Lucia: Is there one downstairs?
Lucia:啊那行
Lucia: Oh, okay.
其他人：OK
Others: OK
其他人：走吧刘帅
Others: Let's go, Choiszt.
Katrina: 卧槽太屌了
Katrina: Whoa, that's awesome!
Tasha: 为什么要把他们强行塞在一起
Tasha: Why do we have to force them together?
Jake:方便拍照
Jake: For taking photos.
Jake:咱还有道具呢
Jake: We also have props.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:在后面再摆一个显得很多
Jake: Putting one more at the back will make it look like a lot.
Alice:你你能不能把这个汇源果汁挡一下
Alice: Can you cover the Huiyuan juice?
Jake:我们有整整两大盆
Jake: We have two whole big bowls.
Alice:啊
Alice: Oh.
Alice:就这样
Alice: Just like this.
Alice:勤劳
Alice: Hardworking.
Lucia:嗯嗯嗯
Lucia: Hmm hmm hmm.
Jake:现在还有什
Jake: What else is there?
Jake:还有什么
Jake: What else?
Jake:提拉米苏
Jake: Tiramisu.
Lucia:要用哪个盒子呀
Lucia: Which box should we use?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:垫纸吗用这
Lucia: Should we use this paper?
Lucia:用这个盒吗还是
Lucia: Should we use this box, or...
Alice:用那个就行吧
Alice: That one should be fine.
Lucia:把这俩挪到一个上
Lucia: Move these two onto one.
Jake:对这个先洗洗
Jake: Yeah, let's wash this one first.
Jake:都是买的
Jake: Everything's bought.
Jake:这玩意咋洗
Jake: How do you wash this thing?
Jake:刚刚路亚怎么洗
Jake: How did you wash it just now?
Jake:就擦了擦是吧
Jake: Just wiped it, right?
Lucia:我拿这个擦的就是沾点水擦
Lucia: I used this to wipe it, just with some water.
Lucia:但是就是因为这是木头的
Lucia: But since it's wood...
Lucia:所以他就是上面的有可能会有刺
Lucia: It might have splinters on the surface.
Jake:可能得
Jake: Maybe we should...
Lucia:会把这个稍微刮下来
Lucia: Slightly scrape it off.
Jake:换几张纸
Jake: Change a few papers.
Lucia:直接
Lucia: Directly...
Jake:那厨那那厨房纸有用吗
Jake: Will the kitchen paper work?
Lucia:呃那个好像不能直接用
Lucia: Uh, it seems like we can't use that directly.
Lucia:就是上面不是有那个洗洁精吗
Lucia: So, there's dish soap on top, right?
Lucia:如果你直接擦好就会留在上面
Lucia: If you just wipe it, it will stay on it.
Lucia:或者能直接洗一下可能也行
Lucia: Or maybe you could just wash it directly, that might work too.
Jake:那我过水了
Jake: Then I'll rinse it.
Jake:行我觉得我直接洗一洗
Jake: Okay, I think I'll just wash it.
Lucia:用这个也洗一下吧
Lucia: Also wash it with this.
Tasha: 完了这个盆放不下有没有大点的盆给我
Tasha: Oh no, this basin is too small. Do you have a bigger one?
Lucia:盆盘
Lucia: A basin or a plate?
Lucia:等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Jake:那个大碗是吧哦挺好
Jake: That big bowl, right? Oh, it's pretty good.
Lucia:那个盘哎
Lucia: That plate, hey.
Lucia:这个有没有更大一点
Lucia: Is there a bigger one?
Lucia:或者
Lucia: Or...
Alice:这个吧
Alice: How about this one?
Lucia:这个不太行
Lucia: This one isn't good.
Jake:好这边可以
Jake: Okay, this side is fine.
Alice:这个或者这个这个吧
Alice: This one or this one, this one.
Lucia:这有俩不过这俩应该是一样大的
Lucia: There are two here, but they should be the same size.
Lucia:哦那个碗
Lucia: Oh, that bowl.
Lucia:对那碗能盛的更深一点
Lucia: Yeah, that bowl is deeper.
Alice:我再涮一下吧
Alice: I'll rinse it again.
Lucia:这是什么
Lucia: What is this?
Lucia:酒咖啡
Lucia: Wine coffee?
Jake:戴眼镜吧
Jake: Wear glasses.
Alice:手指饼干呢
Alice: Where are the ladyfingers?
Lucia:这要擦一下吗
Lucia: Do we need to wipe this?
Lucia:拿出来了
Lucia: Got it out.
Lucia:手指饼干
Lucia: Ladyfingers.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia:小心小心
Lucia: Careful, careful.
Shure: 哎你这样放太多了
Shure: Hey, you put too many like this.
Shure: 不行太快了
Shure: No, it's too fast.
Shure: 这饼干什么都不能要了
Shure: These biscuits are ruined.
Shure: 不行没事没事
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
其他人:没事没事我这还有几个
Others: It's okay, I still have a few.
Shure: 我这还有椅子
Shure: I still have chairs.
Jake:嗯你还能吃几个
Jake: Hmm, how many more can you eat?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Shure: 这几个都不能要了
Shure: These few are no good.
Shure: 哦他已经软了对对
Shure: Oh, they're already soft. Yeah, yeah.
Alice:对对我来吧
Alice: Yes, yes, let me do it.
Lucia:拿个勺把它舀出来
Lucia: Use a spoon to scoop it out.
Shure: 对拿筷子
Shure: Yeah, use chopsticks.
Shure: 这几个把咖啡液全部吸走了
Shure: These ones absorbed all the coffee liquid.
Shure: 哎呀哎呀哎呀
Shure: Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Jake:没事你先吃了吧要不
Jake: It's okay, just eat it first.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Lucia:那几个要不要弄一下
Lucia: Should we do something about those?
Shure: 我想吃个咸鸭蛋
Shure: I want to eat a salted duck egg.
Lucia:还是放那就行那行
Lucia: Just leave it there, that's fine.
Jake:咸鸭蛋
Jake: Salted duck egg.
Shure: 吃过吧小伙伴
Shure: Have you tried it, guys?
其他人:然后再来一盘就能吃了
Others: Then we can eat another plate.